three Prime Minister's visited the  Parliament Islands Leo Vodka debated  Europe's future while Yuri Rattus  discussed Estonia is outgoing EU council  presidency  Boyko Borissov outlined plans for  Bulgaria's presidency a clean energy  package would cut energy consumption in  the EU by 35 percent from 2005 levels by  2030 members of parliament called for an  increased use of renewable energy across  Europe around twenty five point eight  million tonnes of plastic are generated  in the EU every year the EU is launching  a plastic strategy to cut down on waste  modernize recycling and invest in  research of innovative materials with  402 votes to 232 Parliament called for a  ban on an electrical pulse fishing a  practice that pushes fish up from the  seabed and Internet's using electric  currents MEP s still have to convince  state governments MEP 'z debated the  rise of Russian influence in EU  countries back in 2016 they had warned  the Kremlin was stepping up its  propaganda efforts